not they're not doing anything that's
substantially different it's a lot of
the same techniques you go up on Capitol
Hill you try to get journalists to write
things that are favorable to your cause
when they don't write things favorable
your protest you do the same things that
the National Rifle Association is you
make sure that congressmen understand
that if they take positions contrary to
what you want you're gonna try to steer
campaign contributions to the other side
if at all possible
so the nature of the activities is
pretty similar to what other powerful
groups do as well
why is Social Security a sacrosanct
third rail issue it's because the AARP
has a position of that and they can
organize their members and so a
politician who suddenly steps up and
says you know I think Social Security
ought to be cut is going to be in real
trouble for doing that so that what
they're doing is not all that different
they are particularly good at it but
they're not doing anything that's
illegitimate with one exception which is
the tendency to smear anybody who is
critical in this relationship for being
anti-semitic or being bigoted in some
way so what happened to Jimmy Carter for
example after he published his book
Palestine peace not apartheid is a
classic example of this for he was
accused of being a Nazi sympathizer
accused of being a Jew hater etc etc and
this is a president who had done as much
for Israeli security as any American
president ever has that I think is not
legitimate because it gets in the way of
free and open discourse which is really
essential in a democracy you could
certainly diminish the impact of all
special interest groups if you could
have a really radical campaign finance
reform in the United States it wouldn't
end interest group politics but it would
take some of the fuel out of it and that
I don't think is gonna happen in my
lifetime because of course that would
get resisted by all special interest
groups not any particular one I think
because there's nothing wrong with
any group of Americans organizing to
shape American foreign policy in ways
that they think are good for the country
I don't favor putting any restrictions
or limits or saying that you guys can't
organize you can't come up on Capitol
Hill any more and talk to congressmen I
think anything like that would be very
anti-american very anti-democratic Oh
what I hope happens and what I hope our
book helps encourage is that some of the
organizations and sort of broad
coalition which doesn't agree on
everything by the way they some of the
more moderate groups and more
progressive groups become more
influential gained more supporters and
similarly some of the more powerful
groups now that tend to be more hardline
begin to rethink their positions I would
have no objection to their being a very
powerful pro-israel community in the
United States if I thought the policies
they were pushing for were better for us
and better for Israel as well so I have
no problem with there being Lobby I just
wish it were pushing for policies that
were smarter